[Music]
this show is a little off the beaten
track and it may be unexpected and
surprising so taste it and enjoy my name
is Jeff Goldblum the name of the show is
the world according to Jeff Goldblum be
forewarned I'm in the show a lot I'm
sort of fascinated by a lot of things
sneakers these shoes are worth 12
$15,000 or denim ice cream like I guess
what kind of ice cream you want jewelry
isn't that something
tattoos I like that and then every once
in a while I break into song
zigu khon kaen so the game goes on so
okay
anyway what were we talking about this
is what the show is gonna be like so do
any of this tempts you or we're ease you
you can make a decision right here
I followed my own natural curiosity do
you believe in ghosts are you sing
Anchors Aweigh and you make a sound like
a seagull Notting Hill you ever see that
movie engineer my skin what other Irish
songs do I know if I were to meet that
we put in a Korean barbecue what would I
be I'm not here to be didactic or
professorial in any way it's like a
funhouse
I know nothing that's the premise I'm a
humble student
and in fact a kind of a late bloomer
[Music]
a late goat bloomer
[Music]